Lamport's clock gave a fundamental ordering mechanism for events in a
distributed system. This theoretical basis is all the more important in this day
and age, when so many everyday services, email, social networks, e-commerce, and
now even online education are becoming
distributive. Incidentally, this is the same Lamport
who gave us a way to order
memory accesses in a shared memory multi-processors, through
the sequential consistency memory model. In the next
part of the lesson we turn our attention
to more practical matters in distributed systems. Specifically,
given that network communication is the key to
performance for distributed services, the operating system has
to strive hard to reduce the latency incurred
in the system software for network services. Lamport's clock serves as the
theoretical underpinning for achieving deterministic execution
in a distributed system, despite the non
determinism that exists due to the vagaries of a network. In this lesson, we
will discuss techniques for making the operating system softwares tag efficient
for network communication. Both by looking
at application interface to the kernel as
well as inside the kernel in the protocol stack itself, but first a quiz.